do you feel like the left's Turning
Trump into a martyr with this action
well that's exactly what's happening
they've been the left is they've been
going after Trump now for decades it's
just that in the last four or six years
Russia collusion all that's the
impeachment and everything they're
they're concerned about Donald Trump and
you have to ask yourself you know if
Donald Trump truly lost the 2020
election why are they going after him
now right well I mean if he truly lost
the election why are they going after
him you would think
seven million votes right 2020 what do
you lose by 7 million 71 million it was
like 10 or something okay 11 million or
maybe maybe you're right maybe it was
like seven or eight okay but the point
is he lost by several million he lost
the electors by 60 or 70. you would
think you'd want the same guy coming
back in four years why don't they want
that man coming back why do they because
they have to paint him as a as is like a
criminal that this guy's got to be put
in jail putting handcuffs because
there's people afraid of them because
people saw Joe Biden